all right packs rundown recap rerun cap
down so packs prime is already long over
and everyone else has covered the bigger
stuff the news the panels the highlights
the cosplay the awesome people the
parties so what's my take on it that's
relevant to me ends of the channel well
there's the human element the overall
story of flying down from Canada seeing
the west coast forest fires from the sky
the smoke gathering in the mountain
valleys as the Sun sets there's standing
in line followed by more standing in
line followed by standing in large
crowds
there's hanging out with awesome people
at parties there's meeting people you
deeply respect and turning into a
blubbering fanboy meeting Felicia really
was the high point for me though no joke
it was it was big for me
so there's all the noise and chaos and
fun and boredom and new short term
friends and all of that but what's to be
sussed out well here's something to talk
about are you familiar with pin trading
so Penny Arcade is something that the PA
people started a few years ago based off
of the pin trading thing that Disneyland
does the PA merch team along with a
handful of other companies like Wizards
of the coast make official trading pins
and then fans collect and trade them and
that right there is pretty much the line
that's the sum total volume of
information that 90% of you care about
ever hearing but bear with me for a
second so there's an internal economy to
the trading different pins are of course
harder or easier to get a hold of some
are produced in huge numbers and are
widely available at a variety of
different events while others are
produced in incredibly limited
quantities and available only through
ridiculously circuitous means some are
just sold as general myrcella's cost
time or effort or just dumb luck the
community has developed its own jargon
to describe the economy such as a pay
pin versus a play pin a pin that can be
bought as general merge versus one that
you get by playing a company's demo
fodder pins or low value pins that are
used to fuel other trades especially
with the Penny Arcade staff who have
special trading rules and their own
unique pin various people gain some
measure of status or notoriety in the
community by virtue of having a large
election or being a toxic traitor or
just being particularly active on the
community forums in fact on Sunday night
because I am nothing if not a huge nerd
I went to the big trading event at the
Westin Hotel my modest collection of
pins hanging around my neck on a lanyard
and I stumbled into subculture history
as I watched two people spend the better
part of an hour hashing out a trade over
the coveted Kickstarter pin and despite
the fact that I had never before heard
of this pin prior to the event and was
in every way shape and form a new
initiative oaken I found myself a part
of the enthralled crowd watching the
trade my excitement rising as they
bargained running down checklists and
counting and recounting the inventory at
stake and along with everyone else
watching I clapped and cheered when they
shook hands and sealed the trade it was
fascinating
it was subculture in motion a microcosm
of language and culture and value and I
got caught up in it in a big way in fact
I spent most of the convention chasing
down pins getting duplicates that I
could use to trade for pins that I
wanted making trades for pins that I
figure other people will want in the
future and that in turn will let me
leverage four pins that I want to have I
arrived on Friday with a single lanyard
of straggler pins left over from 2014
and by Monday I had upgraded to a pin
wallet because as my friend said I was
starting to look like mr. T and I
jingled when I walked and you know what
I enjoyed it because and maybe this is
just something that's been on my mind
lately
but it's easy to become cynical and to
associate criticism with cynicism you go
to something like pax and it's huge and
bombastic and loud tens of thousands of
square feet dedicated to companies
erecting miniature temples to themselves
investing tens of thousands of dollars
into getting people hyped for their
products the pin trading itself is root
and branch an alternate revenue stream
that doubles as promotional material I
spent a ridiculous amount of time around
mo t cos booth for gigantic because the
T open was a pain in the ass to get but
I wanted it both for completion and
because it's actually pretty sweet yes
it was 100% promotional and it worked I
hadn't even heard of mo t go or gigantic
prior to pax but now I'm honestly kind
of excited to play the beta when it goes
live so here's the thing just because
there's people out there whose job
is to generate hype doesn't mean we
should feel bad about being hyped we can
be both things we can be critical of
culture and its products we can be aware
of the mechanisms of subculture and how
we interface with them we can and should
be cognizant and critical and even a
little suspicious of where corporation
and culture meet where subcultures form
around consumption and we can still let
ourselves get excited and enjoy the
human connections that we form in those
spaces as microcosmic and oblique as
they may be and so go in peace my
children in the name of like share and
subscribe
amen